Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans
"Ces idées qui gouvernent le monde".
"Ce que l'Europe doit aux Juifs."
La civilisation européenne
s'est construite
siècle après siècle,
génération après génération,
du génie de ses populations,
des événements politiques,
militaires, religieux,
d'un extraordinaire
brassage culturel et géographique,
et d'innovations de tous ordres
qui ont contribué
aux progrès de l'humanité
et à l'universalité des valeurs.
"Les Juifs ont leur part,
leur influence",
selon Pierre Manent,
"dans ce chemin civilisationnel
"participant
à toutes les aventures de l'esprit
"avec l'intelligence des modernes",
selon le sociologue Emile Durkheim,
en demeurant, je cite,
"toujours citoyens",
d'après Jean-Jacques Rousseau,
et en cultivant
une altérité ancestrale
à rechercher du côté
des origines bibliques
et talmudiques,
de leurs épreuves séculaires
et d'une aptitude socioculturelle
remarquable.
Ce cheminement côte à côte
des Juifs et de l'Europe,
objet de notre émission,
sera moins hagiographique
ou apologétique.
Ni sacralisation ni éblouissement.
Simplement,
il s'agira de discerner
l'influence de la pensée juive
dans l'histoire de la philosophie,
de la politique,
des sciences,
des arts, des religions,
et tout simplement des comportements
qui ont fait l'Europe d'hier
et d'aujourd'hui,
et peut-être de demain.
Je vous propose
une espèce de narration biographique
de ce que l'Europe doit aux Juifs
avec mes invités.
Vincent Peillon,
vous êtes ancien ministre
de l'Education nationale,
vous êtes philosophe.
Pascal Ory,
vous êtes historien
de l'Académie française.
Armand Laferrère,
vous êtes normalien et essayiste.
Pierre Nora, vous êtes historien
de l'Académie française.
Vous avez vu
ce que Milan Kundera
dit du génie juif.
"Etrangers partout
et partout chez eux."
Comment expliquez-vous,
Vincent Peillon,
que l'esprit juif cultive
cette contradiction apparente
entre garder une distance
et être dans la proximité ?
En somme,
de conjuguer l'universel
et le particularisme ?
-D'abord, c'est sans doute...
Le danger de notre thème,
c'est qu'on embrasse très large
et qu'on peut mal étreindre.
Si je veux répondre
à votre question,
je dirai deux choses.
La première, il y a sans doute
quelque chose d'ordre historique.
C'est-à-dire un peuple élu
qui a un rapport direct avec Dieu
et une mission à accomplir,
pas une mission pour lui-même,
mais une mission universelle.
Mais précisément...
Donc vous voyez bien
que vous avez déjà une articulation
entre un particulier,
un peuple singulier, élu,
mais élu pas
pour regarder son nombril
ou se satisfaire lui-même,
élu pour porter un message,
qui va s'amplifier dans l'histoire,
un message universaliste.
Cette tension va
historiquement se durcir
- c'est après
ce que l'on va appeler
- le judaïsme des rabbins -
parce que le conflit
entre une secte juive,
le christianisme,
et le christianisme originaire
des Juifs
va être une tension,
justement,
entre deux universels.
La clôture juive,
ça va être une façon
de préserver ce lien singulier
entre le particulier
et l'universel.
Alors, c'est le deuxième point.
On pourrait penser,
comme le proposent
certains philosophes,
- c'est très actuel par rapport
aux débats politiques en France -
qu'il y a deux types d'universel.
Un universel chrétien
au sens de l'empire :
"Je réunis tout le monde,
mais ça doit être le même.
"Renonce à ta différence."
Et un universalisme juif qui dirait
que l'universel se construit
dans le respect
de toutes les différences.
Le Juif n'est pas prosélyte.
Des philosophes
comme Levinas ou André Neher
ont beaucoup insisté
sur cette idée qui nous amène
aussi à réfléchir sur le sens
du républicanisme français,
l'intégration et l'assimilation.
-On va rentrer dans le détail,
mais juste un mot :
comment vous distinguez
l'hébraïsme du judaïsme ?
-Bon.
-Parce que vous avez tendance
à dire qu'avant,
c'était l'hébraïsme,
et le judaïsme des rabbins, après.
Il n'y a pas
une filiation directe ?
-Directe, sans doute, mais vous avez
deux voies différentes.
Vous avez une voie
qui est celle de l'hébraïsme,
c'est-à-dire d'un peuple
qui a existé historiquement
et qui vivait sous la loi de Moïse,
qui est dans le Pentateuque,
auquel un certain nombre
de savants du 19e disent :
"Il faut revenir."
Vous avez Spinoza
et la République des Hébreux.
Puis vous avez le judaïsme,
c'est d'autres textes,
c'est une tradition
qui va exister au Moyen âge,
qui va produire des textes,
une tradition.
Il y a même, au 19e siècle
dans le judaïsme français,
un conflit
entre les uns et les autres.
Certains disent
qu'il faut revenir à l'hébraïsme,
au judaïsme des origines...
-On détaillera...
-... et quitter le judaïsme
des rabbins qui est trop orthodoxe,
fermé sur lui-même,
du texte plutôt que de l'esprit.
-On va détailler.
Pierre Nora,
je pense
que vous vouliez dire un mot
sur la distinction
entre l'universel
et le particularisme.
-Je suis un peu dépassé
par ce sujet, j'avoue.
Euh...
J'aurais tendance...
A propos, je pense
que je suis le seul Juif.
A part vous.
-Non, non, pas du tout.
-Je ne suis pas le seul ?
Sans quoi
je me serais permis...
-Vous n'avez pas
cette exclusivité.
-... ils ont apporté
à l'Europe
des emmerdements.
-Et réciproquement.
Rires
Et que Marx,
Freud,
tout ça, c'est quand même...
-Jésus !
N'oubliez pas Jésus.
-... et Jésus,
ça fait beaucoup de troubles
dans la cité antique.
-Les trois que vous citez
sont universels.
-Oui, il n'y a pas qu'en Europe...
-Qu'est-ce que vous leur trouvez
de particulier ?
-Ils ont apporté la peste.
L'un est père
du totalitarisme contemporain
et du communisme
qui a empoisonné le monde.
Le deuxième
est un totalitaire
de l'inconscient
qui a lui aussi compliqué
les choses singulièrement.
Je plaisante, bien sûr.
Vous m'avez compris.
Et l'expérience plus récente
de la Shoah
fait interpréter
beaucoup de choses.
Je crois qu'à votre réponse,
M. Malet, il faudrait d'abord
distinguer aussi
plusieurs types de judaïsme.
Le judaïsme
des pays assimilés de l'Europe,
si j'ose dire,
ce n'est pas le même
que le pays...
Que le judaïsme
des pays orientaux.
-Par l'histoire,
c'est la même chose.
-Leur destin, ça n'est pas le même.
Et même par l'histoire.
Ca n'a pas été du tout la même.
Pas du tout la même. Jusque...
Le judaïsme européen,
et spécialement français,
a été,
jusqu'à la Shoah,
un judaïsme d'assimilation
très puissant,
et s'il n'y avait pas eu
probablement la Shoah,
ce serait achevé
par l'assimilation complète
et à la limite,
la disparition du judaïsme...
En Orient,
c'est la même chose,
dans l'Europe orientale.
C'est un judaïsme
beaucoup plus démocratique,
beaucoup plus populaire,
beaucoup plus...
ethnique,
beaucoup plus communautariste,
et leur destin
n'a quand même pas été le même
justement dans l'extermination.
A l'est, il a été
sinon radical,
du moins attendu à l'être.
En France en particulier,
il a été beaucoup plus...
scrupuleux,
si j'ose dire.
Donc,
à tous ces égards,
il y a eu plusieurs
formes de vie en Europe.
Et, personnellement,
ce qui m'a le plus intéressé,
c'est le judaïsme français,
qui a évidemment un destin
qui lui est très particulier
et qui est profondément
lié à la francité.
-On va rentrer...
Vous allez voir, on va en parler.
Peut-être, Armand Laferrère,
sur cette distinction
entre le pari d'universalité
et quand même un particularisme
qui se montre.
-Oui.
Le judaïsme est un peu le lieu
où cette distinction
perd beaucoup de son sens.
Le judaïsme...
Les Juifs sont un peuple.
Ils n'ont pas l'intention
d'être autre chose.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils ont apporté
à la pensée européenne ?
L'idée qu'il y a eu un seul Dieu
et une seule morale.
C'est-à-dire
l'universalité la plus absolue.
Jusqu'à aujourd'hui,
une partie des peuples européens
ont un ressentiment profond
envers cette idée
qu'il y a une morale
qui va au-delà du fait
qu'on défend notre tribu,
on massacre celle d'à côté,
et après,
on boit un verre.
Et le fond...
C'est un sujet gigantesque,
les relations
entre l'Europe et les Juifs.
D'ailleurs,
il y a une série de conférences
qui ont commencé
et qui se feront sur 2023,
sous l'égide d'un certain
Emile Malet.
Peut-être que c'était
le moment de le signaler.
Mais l'apport d'un message universel
par un peuple qui tient
à sa particularité
est au coeur
d'une relation qui forcément
devait être compliquée.
Nous avons dit aux Européens :
"Nous avons un message
"qui vaut pour tout le monde
et ne nous embêtez pas
"quand nous ferons
notre petite chose."
-M. Laferrère,
est-ce que vous voulez dire
qu'il y a un message d'éternité ?
-Je ne sais pas si c'est ça.
Il y a un message d'éternité
parce que l'Eternel,
comme son nom l'indique.
Il hésite.
C'est surtout un message
d'universalité apporté
au même moment où nous avons refusé
toutes les ambitions européennes
et autres à l'universalité.
Il y a les musulmans aussi.
Il y a eu des vagues idéologiques :
"Tout le monde doit être chrétien,
"c'est la solution.
"Tout le monde doit
"être rationaliste..."
-En mai 68,
tout le monde devait être juif.
-"Tout le monde
doit être socialiste."
Il y a eu ces messages,
et à chaque fois, il y avait
un petit peuple qui disait
que c'était joliment dit,
mais qu'il allait agiter son loulav.
-Et on voit ce que ça donne,
l'universalisme.
-Et le même peuple...
Et c'est le même peuple
qui avait dit :
"La morale, c'est sérieux.
Dieu, c'est sérieux.
"Ca vaut pour tout le monde."
Ca ne pouvait qu'être
en partie conflictuel,
même si ça n'a pas été que ça.
-Pascal Ory,
je voudrais aller plus loin
et vous chatouiller
sur le côté historien.
Vous avez vu,
Jean-Jacques Rousseau dit :
"Les Juifs sont toujours citoyens."
Comment vous expliquez cette chose ?
Citoyens, toujours,
citoyens de prédestination ?
-Citoyens assez tardifs par rapport
à la plupart des chrétiens
de ces institutions politiques
d'essence chrétienne qui constituent
grosso modo l'Occident.
Mais je voudrais répondre
aux questions
que vous avez posées...
-Oui.
-... par une remarque
concernant un groupe
qui n'a pas encore été cité,
qui me paraît capital
pour comprendre
le fait que le statut
des Juifs a changé,
qui sont les protestants.
Il y a une sorte
de remarque presque triviale
que je voudrais faire.
C'est issu d'un travail récent
sur la judéophobie.
Pourquoi et comment est-ce que...
le statut des Juifs va bouger
à partir du 16e siècle,
17e, 18e...
Bon, Cromwell,
la Révolution française,
les différents édits de tolérance,
l'émancipation du peuple juif.
La réponse est
quand même vertigineuse.
Personne n'y pense.
Ce n'est pas dû à une révolte juive,
que je sache.
Je prends une loupe,
je n'en trouve pas.
Il s'est passé
un changement chez les goys.
Eh bien oui !
Sinon, actuellement,
il y aurait toujours
la situation médiévale.
-Dites ce que veut dire goys.
-Non-Juif.
Ce que je suis personnellement.
C'est quelque chose
qui s'est passé là,
et le protestantisme...
La Réforme est essentielle,
parce qu'on sait
qu'on peut avoir un regard
sur Luther
ou sur Calvin assez...
critique dans leur évolution,
à l'un et à l'autre,
surtout à Luther
à l'égard des Juifs,
mais là où ça commence à bouger,
à la fin du 16e,
c'est chez les calvinistes,
chez beaucoup de pasteurs.
Pourquoi ?
C'est facile.
Encore aujourd'hui, en ce moment,
dans le christianisme,
où y a-t-il une référence
vétérotestamentaire ?
C'est le protestantisme.
C'est un moment essentiel.
D'une certaine façon,
l'avenir du peuple juif est passé
par le protestantisme.
Le monde moderne...
-Qui est quand même plus tardif.
-Ben non, 16e.
16e siècle, avant,
ça ne bouge fondamentalement pas.
-Puisqu'on parle de bouger,
je voudrais vous poser
cette question.
De Théodore Reinach
à Ernest Renan,
il y a ce sentiment
que le Juif exprime
l'esprit moderne.
Ce que le philosophe
Vladimir Jankélévitch
nomme "la motilité juive".
Est-ce que c'est
une avancée de civilisation
qui est ainsi apportée
et est-ce que c'est
ce qui a apporté
à la civilisation européenne
ses grandes transformations ?
Vincent Peillon.
-Pascal Ory soulève
un très grand débat
chez les historiens,
les philosophes et les politologues.
D'abord, ce qu'il dit est
juste historiquement.
Pourquoi ?
Les Protestants disent
qu'il faut revenir au texte même.
"Je vais lire directement
le texte sans passer
"par une Eglise,
un prêtre, un interprète."
Qu'est-ce que le texte ?
C'est la bible hébraïque.
A ce moment-là s'ouvrent,
dans toute l'Europe,
les chaires d'hébraïsme, etc.
Il y a un retour
à ce moment-là du judaïsme,
en tout cas de la bible hébraïque,
dans la civilisation
devenue chrétienne,
mais la vraie question qui se pose
depuis une quinzaine d'années
pour les chercheurs,
c'est de savoir ce qui revient
avec la bible hébraïque.
Parce que le grand processus
de la sécularisation,
de la modernité évoquée,
il n'introduit pas
les Juifs.
On parle d'origines
chrétiennes de l'Europe.
Au Parlement européen,
on parle d'origines chrétiennes.
Or, que se passe-t-il
aux 16e et 17e ?
La vraie question...
Un professeur de Harvard,
Eric Nelson,
a publié, il y a 10 ans,
le livre
"La République des Hébreux",
qui est dans le monde entier
et qui a été ce grand débat.
La modernité dont vous parlez,
c'est quoi ?
Républicanisme, tolérance,
redistribution
par la justice sociale.
Ces trois éléments n'étaient pas
présents dans la culture réformée.
Mais les réformés
et les calvinistes,
lorsqu'ils lisent
la bible hébraïque,
découvrent
la République des Hébreux,
le dialogue avec David :
"On ne veut pas de roi."
Le républicanisme
n'est plus une solution
parmi d'autres.
Monarchiste...
Non, là, ils disent
que c'est le meilleur modèle.
Il ne faut pas de roi.
Deuxièmement,
il y a chez les Juifs une loi,
qui ressemble à la loi agraire,
dans le fond,
qui est la remise de dettes.
Tous les 6 ans et tous les 50 ans,
on doit libérer les esclaves
et remettre les dettes.
Cette justice redistributive
n'existait plus
dans la pensée des humanistes
de la Renaissance.
Troisièmement, la tolérance.
On n'imagine pas
qu'elle est d'origine juive,
mais il y a
un théologico-politique juif,
non-prosélyte,
qui est pour le pluralisme
des croyances.
Et donc la thèse, et c'est vrai,
que c'est par les protestants,
mais c'est les Juifs qui,
par le protestantisme,
amènent la modernité
et dans la révolution anglaise,
puis française,
avec les textes de Rousseau
sur la République des Hébreux...
J'avais lu Rousseau
au programme
de l'agrégation,
mais on ne le voyait pas.
Il écrit précisément sur ce sujet.
C'est un modèle politique
qui fonctionnera
dans les révolutions
de la modernité.
Aux Etats-Unis aussi.
Vous avez un modèle politique
qui vient
par les protestants pour l'histoire
de la lecture directe,
mais qui est un modèle juif.
La modernité,
c'est quoi ?
C'est la grande question.
Comme disait Foucault,
nous nous interrogeons
sur qui nous sommes,
sur la modernité.
La modernité est juive.
Tout le 19e siècle dont parlait
tout à l'heure Pierre Nora,
tout le 19e siècle français,
en particulier
dans la culture juive française,
après les saint-simoniens,
c'est une interrogation
sur cette question :
"Qu'est-ce que nous apportons ?"
Le commerce international,
la tolérance,
la démocratie, le refus des lois
et la justice sociale.
Ces éléments sont des éléments
fondamentaux dans la modernité.
Au point que le premier rabbin
libéral de Paris
à la synagogue Copernic,
Louis Germain Lévy, dit :
"Le judaïsme sera
la religion laïque
"de la France moderne",
parce que c'est la religion
la plus capable,
voire les procédures talmudiques,
d'intégrer les progrès de la science
et ceux de la démocratie libérale.
-Sur cette idée de modernité,
Pierre Nora,
dans "Une étrange obstination",
votre dernier livre,
vous parlez de ces grands
intellectuels du 20e siècle
qui ont été vos compagnons
de route.
Je pense à Foucault, etc.
Est-ce que vous aviez
ce sentiment qu'entre judaïsme
et modernité,
il y avait une filiation directe ?
-La modernité n'est pas
forcément un progrès,
comme on l'a beaucoup dit.
C'est pas forcément du tout
un progrès.
-Vous vous êtes intéressé
beaucoup à la vie intellectuelle
contemporaine.
-C'est pas un progrès non plus.
Il n'y a pas de véritable progrès
au sens
de la vie intellectuelle.
On ne peut pas dire forcément...
Lévi-Strauss,
puisque vous parlez de Lévi-Strauss,
a montré qu'il n'y avait pas
de progrès de l'humanité,
qu'il ne pouvait y avoir
que des progrès sectoriels
dans la médecine...
Dans un domaine,
il peut y avoir un progrès,
mais en termes globaux
de l'humanité,
on ne peut pas parler
de progrès.
L'invention de l'écriture,
qui a été, a priori,
une grande conquête de l'humanité,
elle a servi,
et il le montre très bien,
à dominer.
A permettre à des ordres
d'aller un peu plus
que ce que la voix permettait
de toucher,
et que c'était un instrument
d'écrasement, de domination
et d'impérialisme.
Est-ce du progrès
ou pas du progrès ?
C'est... L'invention de l'écriture
est incontestablement
une forme de progrès de l'humanité,
et en même temps,
c'est le début de la fin,
le début d'une catastrophe.
Ca veut pas...
Il n'y a pas de progrès humain,
non.
-Pierre Nora,
vous avez signalé
que vous étiez juif,
sinon,
je n'en aurais pas parlé.
-Oui.
-Mais est-ce que vous pensez
que cette chose-là vous a...
Prédéterminé à avoir
le cheminement que vous avez
comme intellectuel,
comme historien,
comme, j'allais dire,
un peu stratège
du champ des idées ?
-Oui,
mais d'une façon très complexe.
Mais pour répondre à votre question,
je crois pas qu'on puisse
attribuer aux Juifs
l'idée-même de la modernité,
sauf...
Sauf qu'au départ du départ,
ils ont apporté à l'humanité
toute entière
ce sans laquelle
elle ne serait pas
l'humanité
que nous connaissons,
c'est-à-dire la loi.
C'est quand même
les inventeurs de la loi
à travers les commandements.
Donc l'idée-même
de la loi à la base,
c'est une idée qui dispense
de la transcendance,
et donc
qui fait l'humanité se faire
elle-même
et donc qui projette
le judaïsme
dans une histoire.
Dans une histoire.
Puisque vous parlez de mon livre,
j'essaye de dire
que le judaïsme n'est pas
une religion,
c'est une histoire.
-Et un lieu de mémoire ?
-Le christianisme
est une religion,
et l'islam,
me semble-t-il,
est plutôt une culture
qu'une religion.
Donc c'est très difficile
de dire ce que c'est
qu'une religion.
Je crois pas
que le judaïsme en soit une.
C'est un élément fondamental
de l'humanité
qui est né avec la loi.
-Armand Laferrère,
sur ce point-là ?
-Je voudrais...
Peut-être compléter ce qu'a dit
Vincent Peillon,
avec qui je suis d'accord,
et puis ajouter un point
sur le fait
que tout ne se fait pas
dans le même sens.
Je voudrais compléter,
un apport qui n'est pas mentionné
directement
par l'ouvrage que vous avez cité
mais qui est considérable,
c'est l'apport
du scepticisme
par rapport au pouvoir.
La plus grande partie
des cultures humaines
fait du pouvoir
quelque chose de central,
d'absolu.
Le pharaon est un dieu,
l'empereur de Perse aussi.
Monsieur Poutine n'est pas un dieu
mais il se comporte comme tel.
Y a cette idée
que le pouvoir est inconditionnel.
Les Juifs ont apporté à l'Europe
l'idée que,
"soyons sérieux,
la première chose
"à faire
si vous voulez vraiment un roi,
"on vous le conseille pas
mais bon...
"C'est de faire en sorte
qu'il n'ait pas trop d'argent,
"sinon, il va en abuser."
Dès qu'on a un héros,
et notamment un héros politique
dans le judaïsme,
et dès la Bible,
dans des textes très anciens,
la première chose qu'on fait,
c'est la liste de ses tares,
de ses vices.
Donc c'est quelque chose
qui a été mis au débat
en disant :
"soyez prudents
"et limitez le pouvoir
parce que personne n'en est digne."
Ca a été repris
via le protestantisme
par les constituants américains,
à l'époque où la pensée
politique américaine était
la plus développée du monde.
Ca a pas duré longtemps.
Ca a été intégré
dans la Constitution américaine,
cette limitation.
C'est en complément mais ça va
dans le même sens.
En revanche,
c'est pas seulement les Juifs
qui ont apporté à l'Europe,
il y a eu un grand avantage
donné par la pensée européenne
à la pensée juive,
sous la forme de Lumières,
qui s'est traduite dans la Haskala.
Pendant des siècles...
-La Haskala étant le mouvement
d'émancipation juif,
les Lumières juives
au 18e et 19e.
-Voilà. Autant, jusqu'alors,
le débat se faisait,
franchement, d'un point de vue
de la sophistication
entre egos, c'est-à-dire
que Maïmonide,
quand il commente les Grecs,
il est aussi bon qu'eux,
il montre que...
Autant, au 18e siècle,
les Lumières est quelque chose
qui est parti sans les Juifs,
et heureusement qu'on a pu
les rattraper,
parce que les courants
qui les ont refusés
sont les courants
qui se sont fossilisés.
-Pascal Ory,
vous vouliez dire ?
-Je n'ai pas
une compétence philosophique
suffisante pour intervenir,
thème central
dans cette émission,
sur la contribution intellectuelle
de la pensée juives,
des pensées juives,
on peut le pluraliser,
à la modernité.
Mais je constate,
en tant que modeste historien,
que premièrement,
effectivement,
les Juifs,
non pas la pensée juive,
les Juifs
ont perçu que la modernité
leur était favorable,
que bien entendu,
la tolérance...
Ca, c'est capital.
Ils vont investir réellement,
dans le cas de l'histoire
française,
les Juifs d'Etat...
-On va en parler.
-Il est clair que là,
il y a une association.
Et puis deuxième preuve,
les antisémites pensent tous...
-On va en reparler aussi.
-Les antisémites
de tradition religieuse
pensent évidemment
que les destructeurs
des traditions,
les modernistes,
ce sont les Juifs.
Il y a une sorte d'accord
sur ce plan-là.
Pour le reste,
je voudrais quand même rappeler,
on évoque le christianisme,
c'est une thèse que j'ai défendue :
l'origine de la judéophobie
ne peut être que chrétienne.
C'est un problème.
-C'est un autre problème.
On va en parler.
-Les polythéistes
n'ont pas de problème avec...
-On va en parler.
"Les Juifs sont républicains
"avant la République."
C'est pas trop provocateur ?
Est-ce que...
Ce républicanisme juif
qui anticipe les révolutions,
française,
peut-être américaine ?
Est-ce que vous allez pas
trop loin ?
-Non, vous savez,
ce qui est stupéfiant,
c'est notre propre ignorance,
et elle est politique.
Pourquoi nous ne voulons pas
savoir ?
Entre le 16 et le 17e,
il y a plusieurs centaines
de livres publiés en Europe
dont le titre est
"La République des Hébreux",
en Italie, en Hollande...
J'ai fait mes études,
j'ai écrit
une quinzaine d'ouvrages...
J'ai découvert ça très tardivement.
Ca ne m'a jamais été enseigné.
Parce que l'histoire,
comme disait Alexandre Koyré,
le passé, c'est écrit tout le temps,
mais celui-là a été oublié.
Donc il y a un certain boulot.
C'est exactement pareil
pour la France.
Je peux le dire,
n'étant plus ministre,
je suis un Juif de la République.
Mon arrière-grand-père
était rabbin à Mulhouse.
Ma famille a été touchée
par la Shoah.
Je n'avais pas à le dire.
Les Juifs de la République
agissent dans la République
avec des valeurs
qui ne leur posent aucun problème,
pour la raison
que vous venez de dire,
qui est très précoce.
Ce modèle républicain,
lorsque les Juifs sont émancipés
dans la Révolution française,
ils pensent que le modèle
politique que construit
la France républicaine
correspond à leurs valeurs.
Ils ne sont pas là
passivement,
ils sont là activement.
Quel autre pays que la France
a eu deux ministres
juifs en 1848 ?
1848, deux ministres juifs.
Les finances et le droit.
Nous avons eu un Premier ministre
alors que l'Europe était
sous la coupe nazie
en 36, Léon Blum.
Nous avons eu Mendès France.
Ces fous de la République
n'ont pas à dire
"je suis juif" le matin,
mais ils savent
ce qu'est être juif.
Leur famille leur a transmis
les valeurs du judaïsme.
Ils les transmettent. Ils sont
à l'aise dans la République.
Et ça, c'est très tôt.
C'est notre ignorance...
Platon disait :
"Il faut être étonné
"pour connaître."
En Europe, il y avait 200 livres
"La République des heureux",
sous l'impulsion des protestants,
je le reconnais, au 17e,
et au 16e siècle.
Maintenant,
dans la République française,
il est évident qu'il y a
un problème intellectuel
en France. Le suivant :
si moi, quand je fais mes études,
vous me dites :
"Qui sont les penseurs juifs ?",
j'ai aucun problème.
Weber, Rosenzweig, etc...
C'est ce que nous étudiions
à la Sorbonne.
Ils étaient allemands,
comme Hegel,
Carl Schmitt,
qui était un nazi.
Voilà ce qu'on étudie.
Mais y avait des Juifs en France,
y a eu l'émancipation,
Juifs à l'université française
plus qu'à l'université allemande,
au 19e, les universitaires
allemands viennent
en France parce que, bon.
Mais on ne les étudie pas,
d'où mon gros livre
sur Joseph Salvador
et "Jérusalem n'est pas perdue",
car voilà un Juif français
d'une dimension considérable
qui écrit dès 1822
une "Loi de Moïse" qui a eu
une influence considérable
et sur lequel
on n'a jamais écrit
le moindre ouvrage en France.
J'ai découvert son existence
chez un historien israélien,
Michael Graetz,
traduit
dans les années 90,
sur le judaïsme français,
de la Révolution française
à l'alliance israélite universelle
et qui montrait comment,
dans le mouvement
du saint-simonisme,
un certain nombre de Juifs
ont trouvé, les Rodrigues,
les alévis, etc.,
une intégration possible,
pas au prix de sacrifier
leurs différences,
leurs valeurs.
Nous avons un énorme
travail de recherche,
avec les plus jeunes que nous,
à faire dans les années à venir,
pas s'intéresser
seulement au judaïsme allemand,
formidable,
Gershom Scholem...
Mais il y a un judaïsme français
qui s'est continué...
-Alors, justement...
-...jusqu'à André Neher et d'autres.
-Justement, Vincent Piellon,
Pierre Nora,
Armand Laferrère,
Pascal Ory, j'aimerais
que vous me disiez,
entre Léon Blum,
René Cassin, Georges Mandel,
Pierre Mendès France,
Michel Debré
et ses enfants, Simone Veil,
en quoi, à votre avis,
ils sont l'expression
du républicanisme
et qu'est-ce qu'ils ont en commun ?
C'est un sujet qui est, voilà.
Qui veut intervenir là-dessus ?
Est-ce qu'il y a un petit
trait commun,
est-ce qu'ils ont...
Qu'ont-ils apporté à la République ?
Peut-être Armand Laferrère ?
-Au fond...
-Car ça fait une belle pléiade.
-C'est vrai,
mais le trait commun qu'ils ont
aurait pu ne pas être
un trait commun spécifiquement juif
s'ils n'avaient pas eu
en face d'eux des antisémites.
C'est-à-dire que ce sont tous
des personnalités importantes
de la République française,
ce sont tous, c'est vrai,
y a peut-être
déjà quelque chose là,
des personnalités modérées,
qui sont d'un camp ou de l'autre,
Mandel et Blum, c'était pas
tout à fait pareil,
Veil, c'est encore autre chose,
mais à chaque fois,
on a des socialistes
ou des hommes de droite,
du centre, sans excès.
-Mais je vous rappelle juste
cette chose-là : Jean-Noël Jeanneney
a écrit une pièce de théâtre
mettant en scène Léon Blum
et Georges Mandel.
-Oui, je l'ai bien connu.
-Et c'est à travers le judaïsme
qu'ils ont pu se parler
sur la politique,
parce qu'ils étaient
tous les deux en camp
de concentration.
-Justement,
c'est un peu ce que j'allais dire,
des gens qui sont des bons
républicains et des modérés,
ils ont pas besoin d'être juifs,
ça n'est pas lié,
en revanche, ils ont tous eu
en face d'eux des gens qui ont dit :
est-ce qu'on peut vraiment
vous faire confiance ?
alors que rien,
dans leur comportement,
leur modèle de pensée,
ne s'écartait
de la loyauté avec la France
et cette loyauté a quand même
été remise en cause.
Et lorsqu'on se retrouve
enfermé dans le même camp
de concentration,
la même baraque,
par un envahisseur antisémite,
qu'on ait été des adversaires
politiques,
encore une fois des adversaires
constructifs, bah, forcément,
il faut en revenir à l'origine,
qui était peut-être
une partie de la source.
Mais je crois vraiment
que sans antisémites,
toutes les personnalités
que vous avez mentionnées auraient
fait la même carrière,
aurait eu du point de vue
de la République
le même attachement
et que leur identité juive
leur a été réimposée
par la suite,
même si elle a consti...
contribué à leur formation,
mais comme d'autres,
d'autres sources auraient
pu le faire aussi.
-C'est votre avis,
Pierre Nora ?
-Non, je crois
qu'ils n'auraient pas
fait la même carrière.
Mandel dit
expressément à de Gaulle :
"c'est à vous d'y aller,
"c'est pas à moi".
-"Parce que c'est pas moi",
c'est vrai.
-Euh...
Mendès France est
fondamentalement conditionné,
dans son rapport à la politique,
par le fait qu'il est juif.
Y a peut-être, aussi, une espèce,
je n'ose pas prononcer le mot,
mais une forme de morale,
qu'ils ont en commun.
Morale, je n'ose pas trop le dire,
d'humanisme,
parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de gens humanistes et moraux
sans être juifs, bien entendu,
mais, en principe,
il doit y avoir ça.
Vous me direz,
à partie prenante,
y a aussi l'inverse.
Le nombre de gangsters juifs...
-C'est vrai aussi !
-...spécialement gangsters,
spécialement harceleurs,
spécialement
obsédés sexuels,
spécialement...
-Ou pas spécialement !
-Oui, mais enfin,
on les cite quand même
beaucoup.
Donc vous me direz
que c'est peut-être un peu ambigu.
-On est un peu d'accord :
ils auraient pu porter
les mêmes valeurs et que
le fait qu'ils étaient juifs
et reconnus comme tels
était ce qui les a limités,
ce qui fait que Mandel dit :
"je peux pas y aller
"car je sais
ce qu'on en dira".
C'est la prise en compte
de l'antisémitisme.
-Non, mais ça confirme que,
pour tout homme
politique juif,
cette question se pose.
Et vous en êtes averti très tôt
par des gens qui viennent
vous le dire.
-Vous dire qu'ils sont antisémites.
-Et donc,
y a toujours eu une question
qui s'est posée
pour ceux qui avaient
possibilité d'aller
au premier rang :
est-ce que je ne vais pas faire
plus de mal que de bien
à ma propre histoire
et à ma propre communauté
car je vais réveiller
de l'antisémitisme.
Alors, on évoquait...
La France est ce pays où, en 1936,
Léon Blum peut être
Premier ministre,
mais ce pays où,
en sortant de l'Assemblée,
où nous sommes,
il est interpellé et...
-C'est un lynchage,
il pouvait mourir.
-Il pouvait mourir, voilà.
Donc la France,
c'est ce pays qui a...
Et les Juifs de France
et les Français juifs
le savent parfaitement,
y compris en étant en responsabilité
politique.
-Ils l'ont intériorisé.
-La phase la plus
extraordinaire de ça,
c'est l'affaire Dreyfus,
Alfred Dreyfus est officier
d'état-major
sorti de polytechnique, etc.,
ce qui est inimaginable
dans la plupart
des autres pays chrétiens.
Y aurait jamais eu d'affaire Dreyfus
dans beaucoup de pays
car jamais de Juif
arrivant à ce niveau mais,
évidemment, on a vu la suite.
-Pascal Ory...
-Cela dit,
je précise quand même
que les dreyfusards ont gagné.
Ah oui !
-Heureusement.
-C'est assez exceptionnel
dans l'histoire.
-Pascal Ory...
-La leçon de l'affaire Dreyfus
est là.
-...je voudrais vous interroger
sur cet exotisme.
On a parlé de ces Juifs
républicains modérés,
mais y a une tendance
révolutionnaire.
Pourquoi ces Juifs
ont investi ce terrain
révolutionnaire ?
-Vous poseriez la question
à n'importe qui, toujours,
vous auriez la même réponse :
le sentiment de l'injustice,
bon, en remontant la généalogie,
conduit à des comportements
de radicaux,
de radicaux juifs.
Bon, et très sincèrement,
ça peut se vérifier
quand on regarde,
ce que les antisémites n'ont
pas manqué de faire,
la composition
du parti communiste bolchevique,
quand même,
c'est pas être antisémite
que de le constater,
et on pourrait dire
d'organisations révolutionnaires
plus récentes,
aux alentours de 68.
Donc y a quand même un lien.
D'ailleurs,
ça se retrouve dans les pays
du tiers-monde :
le rôle des Juifs
dans l'émancipation
de pays qui se sont
révélés ensuite
des pays nationalistes arabes,
la surreprésentation de Juifs
aux moments décisifs.
-Vincent Peillon ?
-C'est le prophétisme
juif, vous savez,
dans la tradition même,
par exemple Jaurès,
qui n'avait rien de juif,
il était catholique, dit,
dans un discours qu'il prononce ici,
à l'Assemblée nationale,
en 1913, je crois,
non, peut-être 1911,
il dit que, heureusement,
les Juifs se sont mêlés
à la tradition occidentale,
c'est le prophétisme juif
et c'est un immense
mouvement de justice.
Ca, pour un socialiste,
c'est pas rien,
lui, c'était quasiment
sa théologie laïque.
Ca vient du prophétisme juif.
Donc les Juifs nous ont laissé ça.
Le philosophe Merleau-Ponty disait
la même chose 30 ans plus tard,
lui aussi catholique, il dit,
dans le fond, et c'est un moment
de l'histoire du judaïsme
qui serait intéressant,
où on garde plus le prophétisme
que la loi mosaïque,
hein, mais ce prophétisme juif
enseigne au monde cet impératif
et cet immense mouvement de justice.
Il est pas impensable
de le trouver dans les mouvements
révolutionnaires.
Y a une chose,
par rapport
à votre première question,
qui rejoint cette idée,
car on ne s'est pas fait comprendre.
Le peuple juif,
c'est un peuple-moyen,
c'est-à-dire un moyen,
entre quoi ?
C'est le premier à dire
humanité universelle au début
mais je vous rappelle
l'espérance à la fin,
l'eschatologie,
on se retrouvera tous,
humanité à la fin,
et je suis particulier
parce que
je maintiens cette espérance
de mon côté,
qu'on se retrouve tous à la fin
comme au début.
Donc cette idée, et ça,
c'est très moderne,
on le retrouve chez Kant,
que l'humanité est une au début
et se retrouve une à la fin,
c'est ce que les Juifs
ont apporté à l'Occident.
Ca, c'est considérable.
Les mouvements révolutionnaires,
mais tout mouvement
cosmopolitique,
vous parliez de la Haskala,
ce que Lessing dit
à l'époque de Mendelssohn,
donc, des Juifs, c'est cette idée
de l'éducation du genre humain,
cette idée qu'on va retrouver après,
dans les cosmopolitiques,
qu'il y a une humanité une,
car il y a un Dieu Un,
car il y a une loi une,
car il y a la même morale pour tous,
et on doit la retrouver.
Quand les Juifs se replient,
c'est que ces nations en guerre
oublient ce message
et qu'ils ne sont particuliers
que pour tenir
ce message universel.
Mais si tout le monde le prend,
c'est d'ailleurs
l'espérance protestante,
à la fin, y aura plus de Juifs,
y aura une humanité une.
Ce beau rêve,
qu'on a en eschatologies
révolutionnaires,
en théologies de la Libération,
dans le trotskysme,
tout ce que vous voulez,
le socialisme
français,
quand Jaurès dit, ici,
"c'est l'enseignement
"de ces grands Juifs",
qui dira dans Esaïe,
une larme qui...
une larme qui coule encore
sur la joue de celui qui est pauvre,
opprimé, il faut l'essuyer,
voilà, il faut...
Voilà ce que nous devons faire.
Ce message-là...
-C'est du christianisme.
-Hein ?
-Non, c'est du judaïsme, ça !
C'est la grande querelle, Pierre.
-La compassion...
-Non, Esaïe, c'est pas...
C'est le Pentateuque.
-Ce n'est pas l'apanage des Juifs,
y a la compassion des chrétiens.
-Pardon, y avait beaucoup d'amour,
le mot apparaît beaucoup,
beaucoup dans la Bible juive.
-Mais enfin,
c'est pas du tout un Dieu d'amour.
-Mais je voudrais parler de...
Bah, pardon, mais enfin...
On prie deux fois par jour,
le moment le plus intense,
le coeur de la prière juive,
c'est précédé
par : "béni sois-tu qui as choisi
le peuple d'Israël par amour".
Et juste après, Chema Israël,
qui est le truc...
central.
Je voulais juste dire
quelque chose sur cette histoire
de prophétisme.
Euh, le, euh...
Le problème,
c'est que la religion juive contient
plusieurs courants et que,
quand on lit Amos ou Ezéchiel,
on a assez envie d'aller
sur les barricades.
Mais on a beaucoup moins envie
d'aller sur les barricades
quand on étudie le Talmud.
-Je suis tout à fait
d'accord.
-Et qu'il y a
un courant prophétique
qui peut conduire
au socialisme révolutionnaire
et y a un courant, au contraire,
où on vous explique
que rien n'est simple,
qu'il faut voir tous les détails,
qu'une vérité est compensée
par une autre et c'est d'ailleurs
un problème de la partie philosémite
du christianisme
dans le protestantisme,
c'est que eux lisent
beaucoup les prophètes,
mais pas le Talmud.
Ils ignorent que ça existe.
Et du coup, ils ratent, je pense,
une grosse moitié
de l'identité juive,
qui est la moitié qui n'est pas
la partie prophétique,
la partie le monde a changé,
mais la partie
écoutons paisiblement,
posément,
voyons la situation
et quelles conséquences
en tirer.
Et les deux coexistent
car aucune culture n'est
entièrement cohérente.
-Oui, Pierre Nora ?
-Non, j'allais dire un mot,
là aussi,
un peu inopportun,
si j'ose dire,
c'est-à-dire que,
à notre génération,
il s'est passé plusieurs
phénomènes qui nous ont fait
avoir un regard neuf
et différent sur le judaïsme.
Il s'est passé,
au niveau de toute notre génération,
une renaissance de l'intérêt
pour la pensée juive oblitérée
par la philosophie
chrétienne et qui,
de Maïmonide à Mendelssohn,
etc., a ressurgi
à travers des gens comme Trigano,
et comme d'autres philosophes.
Et c'est toute une... voilà,
qui est liée, évidemment,
à la prise de conscience
de l'unicité
du... de...
du problème juif
et à la tradition positive
du judaïsme,
qui avait été
très largement oblitérée
par le courant assimilateur.
Bon, d'autre part, y a eu
à la fois un double phénomène
qui ne peut pas ne pas...
Il est bouleversant,
dans les deux cas,
l'extermination de masse,
industrielle...
-C'est justement de ça
qu'on a l'intention de parler.
-Et la création d'un Etat neuf.
Et les deux changent si profondément
le regard qu'on peut avoir
sur les Juifs d'Europe
et sur la tradition juive,
sur la singularité juive,
sur le destin juif,
qu'on ne peut plus ne pas penser
la tradition juive à travers
ces deux phénomènes.
-Alors, selon Hannah Arendt,
la mise hors la loi
du peuple juif en Europe
a été suivie de près
par celle de la plupart
des nations européennes.
Alors, vous l'avez évoqué,
Pierre Nora,
deux phénomènes importants
au 20e siècle, d'un côté la Shoah,
de l'autre côté, la création
d'Israël.
Par rapport à notre sujet,
qu'est-ce qui a changé
dans ce destin juif ?
Pascal Ory.
-Je vais être un peu provocateur,
mais le passage de l'antijudaïsme
à l'antisémitisme,
quand je dis passage, pour moi,
les deux continuent à se superposer,
y a tout un antijudaïsme
de source chrétienne
ou de source musulmane
qui prolifère,
c'est pas une substitution,
mais l'antisémitisme, j'allais dire,
vient entre guillemets de la gauche,
vient en tous les cas d'une pensée
qui permet de haïr les Juifs
sans croire qu'il y a un Dieu,
et ça, c'est de l'antisémitisme,
ce qui explique certaines formes
d'antisémitisme récentes
mais fondamentalement
ce qu'il en reste dans l'hitlérisme,
je suis désolé de le dire.
Je voudrais pas faire
du freudisme de bas étage,
mais il est clair
qu'après le trauma,
faut utiliser des termes comme ça,
même si les historiens prennent
des pincettes avec cette métaphore,
mais après le trauma de la Shoah,
il me semble qu'il y a eu quand même
une volonté chez les non-Juifs,
qui sont quand même
majoritaires,
quelle que soit, bon,
mais même, qui étaient
majoritaires avant 33 aussi,
une volonté d'aller explorer
cette culture juive, oblitérée, etc.
Moi, j'ai parlé,
dans mon petit livre,
auquel je faisais
allusion,
de trente glorieuses
de la judéophilie car à force
de travailler sur les phobies,
on oublie qu'il y a des xénophilies,
heureusement, bon.
Prenez la chronologie
des expositions,
des rééditions, des débats,
des colloques entre 1950
et, justement,
ça commence à se compliquer vers 75,
comme par hasard,
vous avez là
un moment
où la culture juive,
Vienne, etc., triomphe.
Et j'y vois, quelque part,
un effet d'un sentiment
de culpabilité mais non juif.
Il faut le dire.
-Et pour cause.
Et pour cause !
-Un double sentiment.
Un sentiment de culpabilité
de la part des non-Juifs et,
de la part des Juifs,
le sentiment que quelque chose
leur était réservé en propre
et qui est l'extermination,
et que ça suffit à faire d'eux
une réappropriation,
comme on disait
dans ces années 70,
de leur singularité.
-Vous avez un changement
qui se lit immédiatement.
Les deux plus grands intellectuels
français en philosophie avant-guerre
sont Léon Brunschvicg
et Henri Bergson.
Ce sont les deux maîtres absolus
de l'université.
Tous deux sont juifs,
personne ne le dit,
ça n'a pas d'intérêt
et eux ne le revendiquent pas.
Bergson a d'ailleurs failli,
à la fin de sa vie,
se convertir.
Après la guerre,
changement total.
Nous, Juifs français,
avons voulu jouer totalement le jeu
de la République.
"Les fous de la République",
de Pierre Birnbaum.
Mais vous vous appeliez
Laurent, Pierre, Jules,
la police de Vichy venait
frapper à votre porte
quand même et vous déporter.
Donc l'interrogation après 45,
Neher, Levinas,
c'est cette assimilation,
cette édulcoration
de notre différence
nous a conduits à quoi ?
Personne nous en a été reconnaissant
car sans se vivre juif,
y a des Juifs français
qui ont été déportés
et tués qui ne se vivaient
pas comme des Juifs.
-Y a un bel exemple,
c'est Marc Bloch.
-Bah bien sûr, absolument,
le grand historien.
-Grand historien,
mort dans les conditions
que vous savez,
résistant, etc.,
et qui, quand même,
dans "La société féodale"
en particulier,
ne parle pratiquement
pas des Juifs.
-Donc vous avez un...
-Bon, y a un judaïsme médiéval
qui est très important !
-Si bien assimilé
qu'il en était un peu honteux,
mais ça n'a pas aidé.
-Oui !
-Il faut le comprendre.
Levinas sur l'assimilation
est extraordinaire
car il dit qu'on ne se rendait
pas compte qu'on respirait
une atmosphère chrétienne,
où on disait qu'on était
tous à égalité
dans la République,
où il y avait toujours
quelque chose de la judéophobie,
venant de très loin.
Et c'est tous
les travaux de Jules Isaac, après,
et les amitiés, le dialogue
entre les juifs et les chrétiens.
Et puis Israël.
Israël en 48.
Alors là,
c'est votre livre de Danny Trom.
Dans la tradition historique
des Juifs,
ça leur a été reproché,
on disait les Juifs vont
être protégés
par les princes,
le fait
qu'ils devenaient...
C'est les livres de Yerushalmi
qui montrent très bien ça,
et donc serviteurs de rois, hein,
parce que nous allions
avoir la protection
des populations par des rapports
directement aux puissants.
Bon, ceci est révolu,
ça n'a pas marché
et ça a été
quand même la surprise,
la surprise
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
et de la Shoah,
les Juif ne pensaient pas
que ça pouvait arriver.
-Vous voulez dire
que la Shoah ou qu'Israël
ne pouvait arriver ?
-Non, l'extermination
de masse uniquement...
Bien entendu.
D'ailleurs, ça a été reproché
par des plus jeunes disant
"vous n'avez pas vu
la difficulté venir",
"vous n'avez pas quitté
l'appartement".
Dans ma famille, heureusement,
certains sont allés les chercher.
-Même les Juifs allemands.
-La formule était :
heureux comme un Juif en France !
Ils venaient de toute l'Europe
en France pour trouver
un asile !
-Qu'ils ont ensuite quittée
pour les Etats-Unis.
-Donc Israël vient jouer,
et ça change toute notre pensée,
la Shoah,
et nous ne sommes plus
les mêmes dans la République
car cette crainte est là.
On ne peut pas avoir été les enfants
de gens qui ont vécu ça,
et Pierre est d'une génération
qui l'a connu,
et ne pas l'avoir là,
ça n'est plus la même chose.
Et deuxièmement, Israël,
quel est son rôle
par rapport à la diaspora ?
C'est le livre de Trom.
Trom dit qu'Israël
pour nous est quand même
le grand protecteur.
L'antisémitisme existe,
la violence envers les Juifs
existe toujours,
et pas qu'à leur égard,
mais à leur égard,
mais il y a quelque part Israël.
-C'est beaucoup
plus compliqué,
beaucoup plus compliqué !
-Pourquoi compliqué ?
-Pour des raisons politiques.
-Des raisons politiques,
mais qui vont tellement loin !
On a longtemps cru que,
dans le rapport Israël-diaspora,
Israël avait une sorte
de leadership,
pour le dire vite,
que c'était là
que se réalisait l'essence
du judaïsme, que, à la limite,
c'était là qu'il fallait aller
pour être un vrai Juif, etc.,
et que la diaspora
était en quelque sorte,
aux marges,
une sorte de juiverie
effilochée
et pas tout à fait casher.
Est-ce que ça ne s'est
pas renversé ?
Est-ce que, aujourd'hui,
d'une certaine façon,
je le dis avec prudence,
c'est pas Israël
qui est le boulet ?
Et pas la diaspora.
Est-ce que c'est
pas en diaspora qu'il se passe
des choses intéressantes ?
Pas du tout en Israël,
sauf dans le domaine scientifique,
littéraire, etc.,
mais pas dans le domaine
proprement civique,
ou politique, etc.
Et l'évolution politique
d'Israël, qui n'est probablement
pas circonstancielle,
mais qui vient de loin...
-Ca vous laisse sceptique.
-Plus que sceptique,
ça me trouble terriblement.
-Sur ce point,
je pense à peu près
exactement l'inverse.
Je reviens pas sur la Shoah,
elle ne définit pas le judaïsme,
c'est ce qui a voulu
détruire le judaïsme
et ils ont échoué.
Donc ça ne le définit
que dans la mesure où ils ont...
ils n'y sont pas parvenus,
nous sommes encore là.
Israël, pour moi,
c'est extrêmement important
parce que, au fond,
c'est le retour à la normal,
un peuple a son pays
et c'est comme ça
que ça devrait être.
-Alors il peut pas être religieux,
je n'en connais aucun.
-Je vous en prie.
-Donc le retour à la normale,
les Juifs ont leur pays de nouveau,
ça fait 1900 ans
que c'était pas le cas,
mais ça a des conséquences
très importantes,
c'est qu'une partie
de la tradition qui s'était créée
parce qu'il n'y avait pas de pays,
sans perdre de sa valeur,
doit forcément être
un peu remise en cause.
Tout ce qui est la loi juive,
la Halakha, a été définie
précisément dans le Talmud alors
qu'il n'y avait déjà plus de pays.
Donc c'est plus
applicable tel quel,
on peut s'en inspirer,
mais c'est plus applicable.
En revanche,
le fait qu'on ait un pays
où y a des débats politiques
qui sont ceux
de ce pays, une démocratie
où se joue en ce moment
le débat central
de toutes les démocraties,
qui est est-ce qu'on fait
une démocratie plutôt directe
ou plutôt libérale,
avec des contrepoids
institutionnels,
ça se joue en ce moment,
mais c'est un débat parfaitement
légitime et normal
au coeur des démocraties.
-Ecoutez, le temps échu
à cette émission
est clos.
Je voudrais vous présenter une brève
bibliographie sur le sujet.
Bon, c'est ce que vous avez montré,
que le républicanisme
et le judaïsme ont partie liée.
Vous êtes allé sur les textes
du 19e siècle
pour puiser
ce républicanisme juif.
Je voudrais signaler quand même
un ouvrage important,
d'un auteur qui prend
de plus en plus d'importance.
C'est une très belle biographie
par le kabbaliste Gershom Scholem.
Je voudrais signaler votre ouvrage,
Armand Laferrère.
Pour vous, y a donc une lecture
politique de la Bible ?
En deux mots,
parce qu'on n'a plus de temps.
-En gros, le livre,
c'est pour comment les Juifs
ont inventé
la séparation des pouvoirs
et ont inventé la nécessité
de restreindre le pouvoir, voilà.
-Voilà.
-250 pages en une phrase.
-Bon, Pascal Ory,
je voudrais signaler de vous
"Ce côté obscur du peuple",
chez Bouquins.
Quel est ce côté obscur du peuple ?
-C'est la situation dans laquelle
on est aujourd'hui !
Tout ce qu'on met
sous les vocables de populismes,
j'ajouterais
la démocratie autoritaire,
qui n'est pas un oxymore,
dans la définition de la démocratie,
y a pas un espace pour la liberté,
c'est la démocratie libérale
qui est libérale
mais la démocratie n'a aucune
raison d'être libérale.
Bon, voilà.
-Un grand débat.
Alors, Pierre Nora,
on en a déjà parlé.
Là, c'est un peu la biographie
d'un intellectuel dans le siècle,
c'est votre cas.
-Dans une époque particulière.
-Puisque vous avez traversé
ce siècle et...
C'est un témoignage, en fait,
vous en faites un lieu de mémoire,
en quelque sorte ?
Vous diriez ça ?
-C'est un témoignage d'époque
qui cherche à faire revivre,
comme on dit,
une époque sans pareille,
une année sans pareille,
ces années 50-90,
qui ont connu une effervescence
intellectuelle
et historienne en France unique.
-Voilà.
Je voudrais signaler
également un numéro spécial
de la revue Passages
qui est consacré
aux grandes figures juives
d'Alsace-Lorraine.
C'est une extraordinaire
concentration,
de Lévi-Strauss à Durkheim,
de Raymond Aron à René Cassin.
On s'interroge pourquoi
cette concentration
dans cette région transfrontalière.
Il me reste à vous remercier,
messieurs,
d'avoir participé
à cette émission que,
pour ma part,
j'ai trouvé fort intéressante
et fort instructive.
Je voudrais remercier
l'équipe de LCP
et, avant de nous quitter,
je voudrais vous laisser
avec cette pensée de Thomas Mann :
"L'histoire se compose
des événements accomplis
"et de ceux qui ne cessent
de se dérouler dans le temps."
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA